from day one since the great victory of
Alexandria Acacio Cortez in her New York
Democratic primary I have expressed
concern about her lack of depth when it
comes to many issues and the way that
that translates into her candidacy is
that I was afraid that when she would
get questioned in more detail about some
of reviews it wouldn't go well and that
unfortunately has happened she was
interviewed on a PBS show called firing
line and it became cringe-worthy ly
obvious that she was sort of speaking
about things she doesn't know much about
when she was asked about the
israeli-palestinian conflict and she was
asked what's your position on Israel and
eventually she was asked to elaborate
and it was a combination of Mis
statements and looking around in a
confused manner silence and just
outright confusion about what seems to
be going on in the region followed by at
the end one of these disclaimers that
she's not actually an expert on this so
why is she even being asked now before I
play the clip I want to clarify
something I don't dislike Alexandria
Acacio Cortez this has nothing to do
with my view on the israeli-palestinian
conflict I think I have a lot in common
with her view on the israeli-palestinian
conflict I think it's okay to use the
word occupation with regard to some of
what's going on there and I already
predict people writing in and saying
David you're a Jew Zionist and you just
don't like this she called Israel
occupiers that's not the problem the
problem is that when she was asked what
she meant she vaguely mentioned
settlements when the real issue around
occupation is Gaza and the West Bank and
this is not a small detail it's sort of
the detail it's really difficult to
watch this but let's make an attempt
let's take a listen but I am of course
the dynamic there in terms of
geopolitics and the world is very
different than people expressing their
First Amendment right to protest well
yes but I also think that what people
are starting to see at least in the
occupation of Palestine is just an
increasing crisis of humanitarian
condition and that to me is just where I
tend to come from on this issue
you use the term the occupation of
Palestine mmm what did you mean by that
Oh
I think it what I meant is like the the
settlements that are increasing in some
of these areas and places where or
Palestinians are experiencing that
difficulty and access to their housing
and homes do you think you can expand on
that yeah I mean I think I'd also just I
I am NOT the expert geopolitics on this
issue so if this is something you don't
know about you don't first fail and then
say I'm not actually an expert right you
say right away this is a complex issue
this affects a lot of people and quite
frankly I'm still working out exactly
what my policy ideas are here but what I
do know is that I want to deal with the
conditions that are afflicting
Palestinians and I also want to do you
you say something as opposed to saying
things that are just so obviously vague
unclear and uninformed and I do find it
annoying when after face-planting
somebody says but I'm not even an expert
on this when Candace Owens did this in
her conversation with Joe Rogan about
climate change I said don't say a bunch
of crazy uninformed stuff and then say
but I don't even really know about this
so you can't hold me accountable I am
not showing you this because I disagree
with Alexandria Acacio cortezes view on
any particular issue I agree with her
that repression of Palestinian rights in
the areas occupied by Israel is a crisis
I'm in favor of working to end that
immediately what I am Telling You is
that what we don't want to do in general
is let people skate by as so-called
progressives without actually knowing
stuff merely because we like their
personality or their talking points or
their identity or the excitement that's
generated around them for whatever
reason Trump won not because of his
views on policy or trade or whatever he
won by catalyzing some really horrible
people around xenophobic ideology on the
Left we've got to call people out when
they're just wrong she was clueless on
this the Simon Wiesenthal Center called
her out saying road to Hell paved with
good intentions and scant knowledge
happy to provide info to Alexandria who
knows zero about 3500 year relationship
of Jewish people to Land of Israel
Jacobins magazine
magazine or Jacobin I'm not exactly sure
how they pronounce it it's a left-wing
magazine often very critical of Israeli
foreign policy they also said that this
interview was not good and it's not
doing anybody any favors and this was my
concern from the get-go I've expressed
concern that she's not totally clear
exactly on what she means by Democratic
Socialist and earlier during this
interview Co she made predictions about
capitalism coming to an end and saying
the u.s. wasn't always a capitalist
country wasn't always having capitalist
roots it did wasn't clear what history
she was pulling from so I'm not saying
she's a bad person I'm not saying she
has bad intentions I'm not saying she
made the wrong decisions on many issues
as an elected official as a potential
elected official what I am saying is
that from the first interviews I saw
with her I perceived her depth of
knowledge to be very limited on a range
of issues and I'm simply wondering
whether thinking about whether this
progressive blue wave that we want are
we satisfied with candidates with this
degree of knowledge or do we want people
who are more involved and I know you go
to the polls with the candidates you
have not the candidates you wish to have
but why not work on getting even better
candidates if you can and if you're
gonna respond to me please none of the
Packman is a scientist she'll stuff I
agree with her on a lot of the substance
this isn't about that you know I call it
like I see it and whoever I disagree
with I'm going to tell you tell me where
she demonstrated depth of knowledge on
the issue we're out of time today great
bonus show sorry no voicemail we'll get
to it all tomorrow appreciate you
watching and listening helping you to
outsmart your list of chores today is
our sponsor filter easy filter easy is a
super convenient subscription service
that makes it impossible to forget to
change your air filters because they
will arrive at your front door exactly
when they need to be changed I for a
while due to a combination of
indifference and incompetence was not
regularly changing my home HVAC filter
and now with my filter easy subscription
I am changing it on the actual right
schedule that it needs to be changed on
and the EPA ranks poor indoor air
quality as one of the top five
environmental
health risks you've got a routinely
replace that air filter and filter easy
makes it simple you can sign up in under
five minutes on your computer or phone
and it is extraordinarily convenient you
just put in the filter that you need and
then it shows up no-brainer when you
need to change that air filter and
that's why I subscribe for listeners and
viewers of our program you can get your
first order free by visiting filter easy
calm or by calling eight five five nine
one zero easy eight five five nine one
zero three two seven nine make sure that
you use the offer code Pakman to get
that first order for free sign up at
filter easy calm to get your first order
free or call eight five five nine one
zero easy
don't forget the coupon code everybody
is better off if you remember the coupon
code PA k ma n